let's jump into this first story which
uh honestly i
i couldn't believe from wrcb tv
nbc late night flights carrying migrant
children arrive in chattanooga
chattanooga's wilson air center is
receiving planes carrying migrant
children
who are being bussed to multiple
southeastern cities
during overnight hours let me just
simplify it for you
this is the bud administration smuggling
migrant children
into this into the central us into these
southeastern states and cities
they say channel 3 obtained video of one
of those planes arraving
arriving friday may 14th shortly before
1 30 a.m
a second video shared with channel 3
shows more children arriving late
saturday night
according to the source who provided the
video a third plane carrying children
arrived friday afternoon
flight records confirmed that a fourth
plane arrived early wednesday morning
may 19th
this is this is amazing did anybody
approve this does anybody know about
this
i mean i'm sure it was approved by
someone in the department of homeland
security
uh you can bet that after the kids in
cages debacle
with you know like the five-fold
increase in illegal immigration to start
the term
that somebody in the body administration
was told that under no circumstances
were there to be more photos of kids
piled up in cages with space blankets
so so now they got videos of kids being
shuffled into planes and flown out to
random cities
i mean probably better optically oddly
enough
right like if we're just trying to avoid
the really you know image that will
disturb
uh joe biden voters it would be the one
of of them being
near the border so out of sight out of
mind right as long as they're
this is i'm sorry man this is
apocalyptically bad in my opinion this
is
a hundred fold worse than kids in cages
they're just like okay we don't want the
kids to be in the cages so
put them on a plane fly them out to
tennessee put them on a bus and ship off
to a group home
everything about the biden policy it's
like the maximum amount of immorality
that you could do with immigration
policy right like
if they had done open borders that would
be less immoral right and if they had
gone full border closure that would be
less immoral they have managed to find
the uncanny valley of the worst
possible policy which is again i mean so
in in tort law there's something called
i don't know if i talked to you about
this before but attractive nuisance
um no what is that so attractive
nuisance
you know normally if somebody trespasses
on your land and gets hurt you're not
liable they trespassed
but if you have something on your land
like a broken merry-go-round or
something what about an apple tree
or who knows and it could be anything
but like something that attracts
children yeah
right and you it leads the children to
trespass and they get hurt
even though they're trespassing you are
liable that's bs
wow what about but i knew i knew about
this because i'm a skateboarder
so uh we at the mini ramp back in philly
we had us we had a no skateboarding sign
on it
so we're like no trespassing and then no
skateboarding allowed right
so so attractive nuisance basically uh
our border is an attractive nuisance
right the promise of
uh getting you know citizenship or the
ability to work in the united states is
what attracts people and the nuisance
part is
the fact that people are having to go
through this unbelievably difficult
journey in order to get it
right they're you know crossing you know
finding themselves in the hands of drug
cartels and human traffickers
uh going through very dangerous journeys
of crossing the rio grande all this sort
of nonsense
um so we're responsible i guess yeah
like the the the bite administration i
think no i mean
the trump administration had the cr you
know a much more moral policy which is
actual deterrence right right like
australia had a similar donation
remember remember when trump said he
wanted moats full of alligators
yeah well i'm kidding he didn't really
say that but they claimed he did that's
good enough i mean
it's it is moral to deter people from
engaging in a dangerous journey didn't
it talk about like lasers or something
too
yeah sure i mean you know australia had
this problem when they had boat people
coming from like fiji and
and islands surrounding it and they had
all these drownings
right tons of drownings in the in the
boats off of australia and they said
they just had a huge policy it's like if
you get here on a boat you're not gonna
be able to stay period
and stop change law what if you have a
merry-go-round and a mouthful of
alligators
if the kids fall in the muffle of
alligators is it a nuisance or deterrent
like
am i in trouble i don't think attractive
nuisance would come into play that would
probably be still a crime
uh i would say so because you're you
know there's there's i don't remember
exactly what the law is but you're not
for example you can't set up like trap
guns
in your house you can see the alligators
bro like i
understand that you can see them but
like the idea is you can't set up like
intentionally fatal traps
on your property because you will be
liable if someone kills themselves
interesting so move to florida where
there's naturally occurring modes full
of alligators
look i i i don't think if the naturally
occurring mozzarella of alligators
that's a
good liability question are you do you
have to remediate that i don't know i
don't know the answer to that well well
anyway
more to the point uh i this is this is
crazy
i you know i knew biden his policies
were in the gutter
and everything was falling apart but
this is a whole new level of bad it's
like
in the middle of the night taking these
unaccompanied children
and shuffling them off to who knows
where how insane so so not only
did joe biden create a poll factor by
getting rid of donald trump's remaining
mexico uh policies so now it's like come
on in catch and release
these some of the many of these people
who had coveted were being released in
texas
when american citizens couldn't even
legally cross the border
then joe biden reopens the homestead
facility
look i get it you got a bunch of kids
you created a problem you need a place
to put them but let's be real
trump shut that facility down they were
complaining about it
joe biden's attractive was it attractive
attractive nuisance yes
pulled these people it created a poll
factor which we we've heard about in the
news all over and over again
so he reopens the the child
concentration camps
aoc's words now mine and then he expands
the mcallen facility so now he's got a
bunch of kids sleeping in the dirt
that's bad and now because the videos
are bad enough
and there's still more kids coming just
shuffle them off who knows where
that's that's that's all that's
depravity when you said pole factory you
mean like it's pulling people in
yeah so when people shut up with shirts
saying please let us in biden
donald trump was like you can't come to
our border we'll shut it down
no no excuse me you stay in mexico
they're like people got scared
if we try and go we'll get arrested and
then sent back and people were worried
that if they went from like you know
bolivia or something or colombia they'd
come up get sent
back all the way to south america and
they're like it's probably better
staying just in tijuana or something
with joe biden he's like come on man we
got to get rid of these these policies
you know trump he's a nazi and so then
he gets rid of them all
and then people start rushing the border
again now it's created a massive
surge it's it's happening what like two
months earlier
so joe biden tried claiming it's
seasonal it's just seasonal migration
and it's like bro this is two months
earlier than seasonal migration no
you've created a poll factor your
policies are awful
trump had it had it functioning not
perfectly it spiked huge
under trump but they had policies and
they were pushing back
body makes it worse this is man this is
nuts it's not seasonal it's
global econo the economy is is trembling
and people are fleeing
their their south american homeland a
lot of people are not even just south
america i saw an
article that said like you had european
economic migrants
african economic migrants crossing the
southern border all right
and that's what it is i mean i saw that
like there was some article that tried
to be like people refugees from
countries hard hit by covid i'm like no
no no that's not a refugee
no no no that's a migrant an economic
right and they're not fleeing
they're not migrating yeah they're
migrating like well
i suppose the easiest thing you can do
is put them on buses and planes and just
uh
yeah in a way it makes sense like
they're clearing up the space although
but the problem then is they're doing it
they try to seem like they want to do it
covertly which yeah it's called
smuggling yeah which is illicitly
transporting people i
made mention earlier that it sounds like
they're it's a conspiracy like
they would be charged with conspiracy
because they're they're transporting
known illegal immigrants across state
borders
i mean aiding and abetting criminals i
mean you know
there's almost certainly some sort of
affirmative defense doing so under color
of law
with the short order you know order from
the executive branch and there's some
probably some statutory authority
you you know that we already have kids
in like orphanages and group
group homes who need loving parents and
are being tossed about the system
the last thing we need is forbidden to
screw everything up and then just
shuffle people under the rug
that's that's sickening that's just why
we don't like democrats it's like why
responsible people
don't don't let democrats run things
well that's why this is so important
yeah but come on man the the republican
party
yeah i i tweeted we need a commission
of medical experts and scientists to
figure out
how several invertebrates and
terrestrial landscape terrestrial snails
somehow managed to imitate english
speech join the republican party and get
elected office
rates yes yes yeah yeah i mean we're
talking about january 6 commission in
30.
35 but come on it's not even that i mean
mitch mcconnell pretends to fight
look at what's going on because of the
fecklessness of the republican party
now i get it a speed bump is better than
nothing
but that's what the republican party is
at this point they're a speed bump for
democrats
oh democrats got to slow down a little
bit they're making too much money oh i
can't stand
these people i don't want to lose faith
in the system i don't want to lose faith
in
the american government because that
could be the beginning of the end
or the end of the end of the system but
they're they're they're making so much
money smuggling kids in that just
talking to each other every day and not
getting much done is enough for them
the democrats are beholden to zealots
the the the
let's let's be let's be real no no no no
no way absolutely not
they they they kick out their zealots
steve king he gets booted from all of
his committees and then he loses his
primary because nobody wanted to hear
what he had to say
you're right omar gets protected by
nancy pelosi
so the democrats for for for what it's
worth
they got spines in spades they will
scream at the top of their lungs
they will bang on the doors of the
supreme court they will storm
into the senate buildings and the media
does nothing why
because their friends have spines in
media got the jobs took over the
institution
the institutions and protect them is it
always been like this
but it's just now their social media so
we see it
i mean to a degree uh you know there was
a time when there was there was actual
like
public cachet and being republican and i
think the iraq war really destroyed that
right like the i'd say that you know
2000 era i mean
still republicans were like the majority
and dominant in the culture but at least
like didn't they didn't they lose the
congress for like 40 years
yeah they did but yeah i mean it was it
was really bad for a while but then i
mean that's all very you know it's a
very different country and that
democratic coalition looks very
different
you know than than i just i just look at
where we're at right where we're at
right now with
democrats and ilhan omar can just shriek
and they're like whatever you say
and the republicans just go okay and
then marjorie taylor greens like two
years ago posted some dumb stuff on
facebook and they're like get rid of
banner from everything yeah she didn't
even say those things while she was a
member of congress
yeah something like and a bunch of
republicans flipped you know went over
on that one too i mean we had something
like a dozen republicans decide they
were going to vote
you know against their own member having
committee
seats the republican party is the
jellyfish party it's just you i mean so
many of these people need to be replaced
and and bullied more effectively like
there's
there's a lack of bullying bullied yes
politically like people need to show up
and protest these 35 jellyfish
yeah or are they just the oligarch party
no no no
the republicans i think are like uh you
ever see
the way this way described it earlier
you ever see the movie this is the end
no i hear it's great though i've seen it
so danny mcbride gets kicked
out of the house and then later on they
find him and he's a cannibal and then he
has
he has that actor i can't remember the
actors james franco's in it
yeah seth rogens in it but that's all i
know he has that that actor
what's that actor's name he was in gi
joe
you know what i'm talking about no
negative chad something i can't remember
his name
but he's a [ __ ] so he's like on all
fours and crawling around
and danny mcbride is a cannibal that's
the republican party is the [ __ ]
in the in the in this in the suit you
know and danny mcbride is a democratic
party
it is sheldon now now to be fair like
they're like 10 republicans
that are fighters you know donald trump
was a fighter donald trump grabbed the
party and yanked it really hard
and that's what people liked so i
tweeted
i tweeted something like the republican
party or jellyfish and then i got a
response from someone who said
all right i said uh yeah they said the
republican party attracts the losers
and i said that's right if somebody
wanted to lie cheat and steal to gain
power
they wouldn't pick the republican party
they'd get the democratic party you know
so
that's effectively what we're seeing is
that p the people
who are manipulative and deceitful and
evil join the democrats and then just
burn things down and strip and extract
and manipulate the ignorant
it's real easy to get a vote when you're
democrat you go to somebody and say hey
i'll give you his money and they're like
deal and the republicans are like
personal responsibility you got to work
hard in meritocracy i'm like
that sounds like work so people vote for
network
so you end up with a republican party
that's just like
a speed bump no one's fighting for
anything
what what what are they fighting for
other than democrats don't do that
democrats don't you do that yeah what do
you stand for
for a long time this has been a
long-term frustration i mean i remember
trying to push for social media
regulation because like we obviously
needed it the dem companies were
controlled by the democrats they were
censoring conservatives
and they're like well no but the free
market it's like okay
i mean and now every you know two years
later when we've lost power everybody's
like oh that was a good idea well we
should totally have done that
um you know we can't count on them can't
count on we're seeing some i mean i'm
seeing some good signs with some of them
like you know
we'll get into the seas the endowments
thing that cotton's doing later
tom cotton's doing that tom cotton well
he's going to tax them so you know
a step in the right direction um you
know taxation is theft
sees it right exactly like i like i like
to seize language we'll get into that
later i get worked up about freedom like
free trade
uh free free market free
freedom because it's not doesn't mean
that there's no interference
if you know the reason that we have a
free society is because we interfere
with it
we create order we create police that
say you can't walk there
at this time stay there don't do this do
this don't do this
so now we have freedom as a result
you're not going to get jumped and
murdered when you're walking around so
you're essentially
free no doesn't mean that it has no
rules so the free market is the same way
if you don't put place rules on the
system
you get run away by that logic prison is
freedom that's not true
well a prisoner has a sort of freedom
health care
guaranteed food right they have a place
to live they're not gonna get
technically they're not gonna get jumped
and murdered because the guards are
watching them well they're not supposed
to because the guards are not freedom
the rules don't make you free
it gives you you need to be responsible
for yourself no it doesn't yeah i think
the united states bro they ban guns they
lost
the law of the land though gives us an
opportunity to create freedom for
ourselves
if there was no law it wouldn't we would
not be in a free society
some laws make sense and a lot of them
don't yes thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you